اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم وسط معارك بين الجيش
والدعم السريع في مدن العاصمه السودانيه
نائب رئيس مجلس السياده يقول على هامش قمه
منظمه الايجاد في جيبوتي ان الحكومه تريد
انهاء الحرب ورئيس المفوضيه الافريقيه
يحذر من حرب اهليه في السودان اذا لم
يتوقف القتال فورا محكمه العدل الدوليه
تقول انه هولندا وكندا طلبت مقاضاه نظام
السوري امامها لزعمهم ارتكابه جرائم تعذيب
وانتهاكات لا حصر لها للقانون الدولي بدءا
من عام 2011 على اقل تقدير كما طلبتاتي خذ
اجراءات طارئه لحمايه المعرضين لخطر
التعذيب مع اشتداد القتال في جبهات عده
الجيش الاوكراني يعلن استعاده السيطره على
بلدات جديده في الشرق والجنوب ويؤكد تحقيق
تقدم في جبهه بخموت والجيش الروسي يؤكد
تصديه لهجمات اوكرانيه
جنوبيه ويتحدث عن شنه هجوما باسلحه بعيده
المدى على القوات الاوكرانيه للمره
الحاديه عشره في تاريخه الاهلي المصري
يتوج بلقب دوري ابطال افريقيا لكره القدم
بعد تعادله مع مستضيفه الوداد المغربي
حامل اللقب بهدف لكل منهما في اياب الدوري
النهائي مستفيدا من فوزه
ذهابا بهدفين لواحد الى اللقاء